oui et ça
ils n'ont jamais eu la moindre remarque
ce que j'ai fait j'ai fait broyer les
branchages et j'en ai mis 10 cm 2 sous b
c'est sa fierté lille beaucoup mieux que
les angry il sans pêche de loisir de
bouger la main mollahs et il est mûr et
les prêts à manger celà
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je ne
[Musique]
on va passer par là a été perçu environ
quelque chose de pas normal je vais me
lancer
et puis surtout j'étais resté à l'inter
parce que je voulais être libre et je me
suis aperçu ivre on était libres nul
voire on ne peut rien décider d'un
assèchement vous êtes obligés d'acheter
les un gars qui sont morts le fmi j'ai
de faire les races qui lisent
on est libre j'étais ballotté
agriculteurs blancs poindre comme un
fonctionnaire il responsable le roi mais
regardez ça pousse tout seul l'aja est
dû oublier un dépôt tête
regardez la hauteur qu'elles ont tous
repousse mais un camp ou désherber et où
rien ne pousse en fugue
c'est foutu et investit 6 et bloque
toute la vie du sol
le sol est mort ni les bulles mon
arrière-grand-père
il avait mis qu'un un qui était pour les
agriculteurs ou ayant essayé un peu ce
qu'il fallait faire mais il y avait un
chapitre où il est surtout ne détruisez
pas ceux qui vous aident tous ces petits
voient jour qui sont d'année ce sont eux
qui nous débarrasse de tout un tas de
vermine et regarder les faits sont
toutes beauté parce qu'il ya plein de
petites chenilles autrefois il y avait
les mésanges et un arrêt des centaines
un parcours et les ombres il n'y avait
plus rien il n'y avait plus rien les
oranje ne devenez pas eu là maintenant
et l'agriculture moderne quand ils
pointent vers m il coupe tout et des
herbes
alors y'a plus loin
ah oui comme l'herbe et drue et serré ça
veut dire qu'il est en bonne santé sont
là mais si on rentrait au moins ils
auront ce souhait
je n'ai jamais traité et ils sont beaux
quand même je m'en irai l'herbe normal
que l'histoire de l'agriculture
biologique alors c'est se transmet pas
vous aviez raison 66 et là l'impression
qu'on est reparti parce que en interne
des intérêts cfm pour yahoo parler d'eux
c'est un coin
[Musique]
mais
je vous montrais vous avez plus de
fermeté et un petit peu sur scène pour
les manipuler j'avais quelques messages
n'y a plus de il n'a plus de 1000 des
commentaires une personne qui mérite le
respect c'est fou quand même non lambert
ça fait plaisir de voir qu'il ya main
qui émergeait son goût un peu coincé
retenu ou voyez même dans la famille ce
qui m'a surpris c'est qu'on n'arrête pas
de parler de ça depuis j'ai l'impression
uniquement la crise du que vides en fait
mary seela et sa femme ils ont la vérité
depuis 66 ça paraît aberrant et maurice
est l'exemple même que l'on peut être
paysan sur peu de terre et gardés les
terres vivantes alors qui pour moi bien
sûr